I think we can get started I'd like to
welcome you all to this last session of
this two-day colloquium just to make
sure you're in the right room this is
the 50th anniversary celebration session
for and our question for this final
session is is capitalism good for
democracy or we could have put the
question more colorless Li as what is
the relationship between capitalism and
democracy now I have the there's I guess
there's been enough turnover between the
two days that I should reintroduce
myself
I'm Josh koa and I teach in philosophy
and I'm the head of the political
science department and for this session
I've been given the easy task of
introducing a question that requires no
explanation and speakers that require no
introduction so I'll be brief least uh
well it may not seem like I'm being
briefed but it'll be brief for me so
writing in the middle of the 19th
century Marx proposed some answers to
the questions of today's session
he said capitalist democracy is possible
only as in his words a spasmodic
exceptional state of things it's
impossible he continues as the normal
form of society and the reasoning for
this conclusion was straightforward
he said the classes whose social slavery
the Constitution is to perpetuate
proletariat peasantry petty bourgeoisie
it that is democracy puts in possession
of political power through universal
suffrage and from the class whose social
power it
sanctions the bourgeoisie withdraws the
political guarantees of this power it
forces the political rule of the
bourgeoisie into democratic conditions
which at every moment helped the hostile
classes to victory and jeopardize the
very foundations of bourgeois society
from the ones it demands that they
should not go forward from political to
social emancipation from the others that
they should not go back from social to
political restoration now Marx was
hardly alone in thinking that the
political equality ingredient and
ingredient in a democratic state
couldn't coexist with the inequality and
private power ingredient in a capitalist
economy that either democracy or
capitalism would win out in the mid 19th
century he shared that outlook with
conservative opponents of universal
suffrage who feared the very thing that
Marx hoped for when this school was
founded in 1950 at MIT it wasn't
uncommon to think that the experience of
the previous 30 years depression fascism
communism and world war had demonstrated
the truth of these earlier arguments
about the irreconcilability of
capitalism and democracy to be sure
there were some who thought that in the
United States at least the New Deal had
saved democratic capitalism but it's
worth recalling the conservative
opponents of the New Deal thought that
it paved the way to a new serfdom and
that even its proponents the New Deal
and democratic capitalism may not have
been entirely confident of its long-term
stability now something has changed in
our understanding of the combination of
capitalism and democracy Marx as well as
the conservative critics of democracy
may have been on to something in
thinking that there are interesting
tensions between capitalism and
democracy
maybe it's an honor maybe it's an
awkward marriage but not every awkward
union ends bad
in any case the confident thesis the
capitalist democracy couldn't last has
been overtaken by events and the aim of
our session this afternoon is to explore
some of the changes in the world and
changes in thinking about the world that
have taken place over the past 50 years
and led to different conceptions of the
relationship between capitalism and
democracy we have three very
distinguished speakers with us who'll
each speak for about 15 to 20 minutes on
our topic after which we'll have some
open discussion and I'll introduce them
now in the order in which they'll speak
our first speaker is Robert Solow whose
Institute professor emeritus and
professor of economics emeritus at MIT
winner of a Nobel Prize in Economics and
National Medal of Science bob is
publicly known for his work on
technological change in economic growth
but he's secretly a lot aiight who
doesn't use email I shouldn't say
doesn't yeah I see Yusei refuses to use
email it's an act of refusal as I
recently rediscovered Kenneth arrow is
the joan kenny professor of economics
emeritus at Stanford also winner of a
Nobel Prize in Economics at a National
Medal of Science and there are three
bodies of work at least that are closely
associated with his name one of which
precisely specifies the conditions under
which Adam Smith's invisible hand
hypothesis about markets is true a
second describes the problems in
combining the separate values of
individuals into a coherent social
valuation and a third on issues about
decision making under uncertainty
Suzanne Berger our third speaker is the
Raphael Dorman and Helen Starbuck
professor of political science and
director of MIT s misty program that is
the MIT initiative on science and
technology she's written on French
politics and more broadly on the
disparate economic impact
of different national ways of organizing
political life Suzanne I can also
testify from after 24 years is the best
colleague you could imagine having now I
know Bob Solow and Suzanne Berger well
although I should say that 10 arrow is
the only one I ever took courses from he
doesn't know but when I was a graduate
student at Harvard I twice in
consecutive years sat through his course
on micro Theory I can't say that I why I
sat through it twice at what I did but I
know I do know all three the work of all
three of them well and I do want to make
a comment that applies to each which is
that they all are known for addressing
topics of large significance with
attention to the demands of reason and
evidence but also without ever losing
sight of the fact that the Social
Sciences are moral Sciences in which the
final stakes are human lives
is it okay can I be heard if I just sit
here and it's on okay well there was a
famous recent occasion in the history of
this country when a question asked of an
important person was answered by the
reply it depends on what you mean by is
the question we're supposed to discuss
here is is capitalism is democracy which
is it is the MA is capitalism good for
democracy but in this case I think it
depends on what you mean by capitalism
actually I should start by by telling
you in an old cliche where I come from
where I'm coming from my most deeply
held political belief is that power
corrupts I don't know if absolute power
corrupts absolutely
these limiting propositions sometimes
hard to work out but I do I do think as
I look at the political world that power
corrupts and therefore for me the the
basic problem of democracy is to avoid
undue concentrations of power to avoid
the accumulation of too much power
almost anywhere actually and certainly
in the in the wrong places
the problem is delicate because some
concentrations of power are needed in a
society because there are economies of
scale not only economies of scale and
production but economies of scale in the
performance of other social functions
and it's very hard to get them done well
without
some group body institution acquiring a
certain amount of power it seems to me
has always seemed to me since I was a
kid actually that I hated school that's
probably where I got this notion that
power corrupts but this goes back along
a long way with me it always seemed to
me that this is the really fundamental
argument against socialism as an
alternative to the capitalism it's true
that there is no real example of the
successful running of socialist economy
but even if that could be fixed even if
one could find ways of operating a
socialist economy efficiently the fact
that it means it involves giving
economic power to the state in a big way
that is attaching economic power to the
locus of political power strikes me as a
recipe for tyranny to have from a
certain degree of abstraction only one
employer in a in a society one source of
Finance and all that suggests to me that
corruption will rose will result in my
youth I had friends who thought that
Stalinism was a perversion of socialism
and I wondered even then if they were
not wrong I personally would have little
or nothing to say against democratic
socialism except the suspicion that it's
an oxymoron
all the socialism's we have observed not
so many but all the ones we've observed
seem to have either originated or
finished in tyranny one of them seems
just to have finished the other day so
coming now to the precise question posed
for this meaning capitalism has going
for it that on paper at least it
separates economic power from from
political power and this this was
thought about explicitly in the
philosophical or origins of in people
like Locke I'm thinking of on paper
capitalism turns private property into a
buffer for the for the individual
against a political power it defines a
sphere in which you are your own in
which you you are your own boss a
person's home is his or her castle to
put it that way but in fact it's not
that simple it's very far from being
that simple
we know from observation and there there
are some good reasons in in principle in
theory for believing it that lace a fair
capitalism tends to generate vast
inequalities of income and even vaster
inequalities of wealth any any
capitalist society living its natural
life so to speak will will will make
these big extremes and in particular
there will be a group of very rich and
very wealthy people leaving aside
whether that kind of inequality is
intrinsically a good thing or
it seems to me that there's an endemic
tendency in capitalist democracies for
the very wealthy to want to buy
political power to use their wealth to
purchase political power we see that all
around us here today most clearly in
campaign financing where the influence
of money on the electoral process is I
think a real danger for a democracy and
this this is not true only of the u.s.
of the u.s. Helmut call got himself into
a lot of trouble for for what by
American standards would be a mere
peccadillo would be something you would
barely report to you or accountant and
and the same thing is true in other
democratic capitalist countries there is
a tendency for wealth to want to buy to
want to buy power it's not Texas oil
tycoons do not play an important role in
our political life because of their
intellectual or moral quality
particularly during during the Reagan
and Bush administration's we had the
spectacle and I was still naive enough
to have been shocked by it not so many
other people were we had the spectacle
of the representatives of big business
sitting with the Republican majorities
of congressional committees writing up
and marking up legislation so the
trouble with unregulated capitalism is
that political power gets absorbed by
economic power to a larger or lesser
extent but sometimes to a very large
extent and so we run the danger of
ending up from this point of view where
social socialism ends up only by the
back door
but with economic power and political
power sitting in the same hands and and
this suggests to me that probably the
best we can do for democracy is
partially regulated capitalism and I
have one could go on at length about the
kinds of regulation that are required
but I'll just mentioned two or three
first of all a capitalism which is does
engage in which the government at least
engages in redistribution of income and
wealth to relieve inequality and to
limit the extreme accumulation of wealth
and therefore of of both economic and
political power secondly one wants
democratic capitalism in which there is
serious public intervention
to limit monopolies and exploitation and
to preserve competition real competition
wherever that is possible and third the
third thing I want to mention now is the
public provision of seriously good
education for everybody - for the
purpose not only of providing a skilled
labor force and all that stuff but to
promote economic and social mobility to
promote the circulation of people
through the economic system one could
imagine easily because we do other other
forms of intervention in economic life
but it's the it seems to me the natural
habitat for democracy is not unregulated
capitalism but regulated capitalism what
we used to call the mixed economy there
will surely be imperfect but it's the
best we can do I want to make only one
more remark now some of you will have
noticed that the sort of society I'm
suggesting as a good idea is exactly
what Hayek Friedrich Hayek in the road
to serfdom was arguing against Josh
mentioned the road to serfdom
parenthetically in his introductory
remarks Hayek thought I presume
seriously that the first steps toward
serf them what I was earlier calling
tyranny are precisely the steps that I
think are necessary to preserve the
compatibility of capitalism and and
democracy as a forecast of course the
the road to serfdom stands as one of the
really great failures
like like Marx's forecast of the
progressive impoverishment of of the
working class in capitalist economies
it's 50 or more years since the road to
serfdom and during that time the the
slippery slope from any trust policy or
regulation of other kinds toward serfdom
has not shown itself at all
I think Hayek could have been seen to be
wrong on the day the road to serfdom was
published because it was perfectly
visible that those capitalist countries
like Norway the Netherlands Sweden which
did more interfering in the economy and
or what according to Hayek have been
further down the road to serfdom than
the more they say fair places like the
United States we're not like that at all
they were both more regulated than the
US and generally more free as open more
open to unconventional ideas than
American society was that may still be
true comparing those countries there is
no reason to suppose that there is a
slippery slope from again what used to
be called the middle way toward
ix notion of serfdom and i guess the
middle way not necessarily sweden is
what i've been advocating this afternoon
thank you the first of all should
explain and Paulo may be quite obvious
to that's I'm not historical scholar or
a political scientist perhaps we'll hear
from professional after I speak that not
this is not my research mind that I'm
acquainted with it's possible to argue
however this is a subject in which
research is online in a real scientific
sense is unlikely to care as much light
as a general impression on what we know
generally make most at least of what
there is to say there's no doubt it
would be illumination and studying
particular historical incidents in the
say for example changes from democracy
to the opposite or dictatorships of one
kind or another or vice versa
I've also and the facts I must say be
having been I would have given a simple
answer and to this question before I was
asked that in fact I did on one occasion
I participated in a written symposium on
the 25th of 30th anniversary I forgot
now of Joseph Schumpeter's capitalism
social and democracy or to some
democracy in which she said capitalism
seems to be a necessary condition for
democracy though clearly not a
sufficient one since there are plenty of
capitalist dictatorships and I have been
have been and there are today but having
this question imposed I've been thinking
a lot about it and so already
I don't know that I should continue but
anything I say now sorted in the middle
of development by thinking one of the
interesting questions well if you can
ask first place what the terms mean what
is democracy and what is capitalism
democracy I think when I don't think
we're the work today definitions are
good enough for us I mean some nominal
legal equality of political power among
a very broad class of people the that
and with accompanied of course by the
political freedom the freedom of the
press freedom of speech and freedom of
assembly and so forth which are
necessary to implement freedom to
criticize some kind of and of course you
can get then into very interesting
question example access to government
documents becomes things there's a
difference between Great Britain the
United States and that respect the and
there are other differences what I found
a little more puzzling and I must say I
don't even know the answer I'm not
prepared to give me answers is what is
capitalist the reason that's important
is putting a sense in the modern-day
world we think of the alternatives
capitalism or socialism historically of
course they're their words there was a
pretty capitalist feudal and at least in
the Western Europe feudal fuel ism is an
alternative and the way we usually tell
the history and I know accurate is of
the emergence of the mod M aquatic
regimes say the gradually developments
in Great Britain or the more sudden
developments so I say in France
revolutionary in a strict sense the are
the ideas usually it's the middle
classes the the MIRR there was an
emerging capitalist system within a
feudal framework and somehow and on good
Marxist lines there was a feast or a
reconciliatory there was a shift of
political power away from the king the
nobles and all that I'm sure that any
realist I am with telling me this is all
that you know it's not really right and
of course we have although this
correspond I believe to Tories account
by the fairies famous account of the
alton of the French Revolutions pointed
out or was the more progressive regions
of France where the revolution was was
not the hopelessly impoverished regions
where the peasants were totally
repressed that was the center of
revolutionary activity so oh you can
give that more than one interpretation
one is it the bourgeois so there is this
association then of the emergence of
democracy with capitalism of course you
go into little details some of this fuss
gets lost and why did Germany develop in
a very different way of 1914 Germany was
a limited democracy that's a there was a
popular election universal suffrage but
the powers of the Reichstag were just
very much less than those of the British
Parliament so the Emperor and his
cabinet still although they had to deal
with the Reichstag by no means
subservient to it in the way that the
British Cabinet is or the American
president being elected these different
forms of responsibility so the so the
now one way of looking at maybe the
capitalist systems were different I'll
come back to this in several forms but I
true through this have no very definite
answer as to what is and this is a
matter in some a great moment not
believe the analysis democracy but even
for the analysis of economic growth as
I'll come back to at a later point the
plus side of course why capitals might
be thought to be a great contributor to
to the preservation of democracy is the
argument that Bob is already given
namely that avoids concentration of
power at least it spreads power economic
power is different from political power
it can provide a kind of a shield for
the location for a dissonance for
different differences which gives
account protection the more I thought
about it the fiction this the more the
less convincing this argument came to me
and the reason there's nothing wrong
with in itself but the trouble is if you
look at the way political powers like
anti-democratic political power is
exercised or even democratic political
power in its populace and majoritarian
phases when it becomes you know when
when the majority presses the minority
is as certainly happened
in various episodes but certainly we
considered dictatorship I cannot be
economic power of the state is usually
one of the least powerful weapons I mean
killing people power putting them in
prison torturing them all rather because
it'll be more effective and depriving of
jobs I think you'll find it in the
Soviet Union for example dissidents who
were not who say we're allowed out of
prison whether they have parties cut
jobs they weren't they weren't kept out
they might might not get the jobs they
felt they deserved but even these
dissident intellectuals usually worked
as a translator some some kind of motive
they weren't really starved to death
except in a couple of cases why you
wanted to go after them they went after
them in much more brutal and effective
ways than them so the economic power is
instrument of repression strikes me is
kind of marginal the additional economic
power conveyed by by this the the gulag
the concentration camps for dissidents
in Germany is a put on the game of
thinking of the death camps now but the
political concentration camps these are
the ways well or to take another example
the beginning of the Chinese when the
China when the Chinese Communists took
over somehow about 30 million former
landlords have disappeared and I think
now it's pretty clear they were just
yeah I'm there the statement was they
were being deported to the border
provinces but it's pretty clear now
they're all just killed they didn't want
anything so this was not at not wasting
time just taking away their land for
example which might be an example of
economic power
it was uneven I mean if the China like
like all of these regimes there you
always find exceptions people who were
treated perfectly well old capitalists
and landlords would be perfectly well
but there was a fair amount of just
plain prison and worse also if
capitalism is good for democracy one
might expect that more capitalism I'm
saying there may be degrees of
capitalism is should lead to more
democracy well of course there's a lot
of problems what do I mean by more
capitalism well one test is the size of
the state
for some what percentage of the national
income of the country goes through the
state roughly the tax bite and as bob
was very pointed out there are countries
like Sweden which to this day over 50%
of the effective percent or so of the
national income goes through the state
and nobody would allege that they're
less democratic in fact some people say
the opposite then those with much
smaller say like Japan in the United
States which have considerably smaller
fractions going through them most
European countries are between Sweden on
one hand and the United States on the
other so it doesn't appear the size that
mideast empirically this is a very crude
empirical statement but at least on a
contemporary using cross-section
analysis as we would say you don't see
much evidence this well other argue
might be that's the wrong criterion
because the state when the state just
takes money from some people gives to
the other it isn't really interfering
with freedom it's not there's not a
direct Congress all you might take state
ownership of industry we have a very
curious example of this the if you look
at the Italy you know from the post-war
period until until about ten years ago
so fifteen years ago they had a rather
large fraction of Italians she was
state-owned this was not a deliberate
policy by the way in the depression the
fascist government was bailing out
failing industries and wound up sort of
just by accident owning a very large
striking Olivetti for example was a
state-owned firm it's been privatized
was a state-owned firm as far as I know
this country was never used for
political purposes it was never an
instrumental thing nobody so that you
had a large fraction of the state
ownership that without any any either
not only did not affect the Italian
democracy but it was nobody even alleged
it was even being used in this way so
I'm getting more skeptical about the
idea state ownership and things are
actually instruments by which democracy
is undermined
now evacs there seem to be cases seem to
be some argument in some sense although
it may be a perverse sense state
ownership may increase democracy one of
the troubles of course one gets if the
democratic power is sufficiently small
that the power of the state is
sufficiently small people in the United
States cause a prime example maybe
uninterested in participating now we
have state ownership one of these you
find every time you have state ownership
is that the employees and managers it's
two for that matter
start exerting political power it sort
of energizes the plate of the democratic
system people get involved of course not
from economics point of view this is a
bad thing but from the point of view of
the viability is that there is it
actually creates an interest in the
workings of the democracy if the
democratic power is sort of itself
unchallengeable then if I want higher
wages I want to keep interesting being
closed down
if scenes in Israel by the which is
another state that has until recently
been a high a high percentage of public
ownership and where the employees are
very vigorously you know L or the
telephone monopoly you've been very
vigorous and an effective by the way in
using the Democrat using their power as
voters to affect government policy now
this may be a bad thing but it's
certainly not a threat to democracy it's
a threat to something else
[Music]
schoolteachers the United States our
significance right at the local this is
more at the local level although it's
insured the public here a campaign also
as you see in the promises of one of the
candidates another possible thing is the
role the state in not in actually either
spending money or in owning things but
in directing resources direct government
controls of one kind or another which
has Baba said there's a whole continuum
of directions now I find very
interesting the examples of developing
countries
we're certainly the philosophy of many
developing countries in the post-war
period was theirs it's hopeless for us
to catch up
I don't less a fair basis the only way
you can do it is by government direction
this was very common fight one might
almost say universal let me take India
Korea and Taiwan in all these countries
the state played a major role directed
resources said you can't do this you can
do that this is through by either by
control over credit control over imports
there's the ways now India started out
with a democratic constitution which is
a it is on the whole managed to maintain
even fending off the Indira Gandhi
attempt to destroy it or limit it Korean
Taiwan started out as authoritarian
regimes what's really interesting is the
state-controlled regimes in case of
India the democracy democracy didn't
preserve the case of Korea and Taiwan
authoritarian regimes have become
democratic precise in an era when the
state was playing major role as they say
so play rated major roles but diminished
in the economy so if the matter how you
define you know the capitalism the
correlation between capitalism or or
less capitalism or less democracy not
the same let me take an even more
striking example I'm watching my time
that's thing where that's the core
question suppose you have a democratic
government and it's capitalist do you
expect this to help fend off a threat to
democracy I've been talking here about
amuri democracies you know the fight
Aryan regimes becoming democratic well
we have a very at least one very
conspicuous case that's Germany in 1933
end of 30 to 33 here we have a pretty
well developed capitalist economy I
don't think anyone would not describe
the German economy as capitalist and a
few feudal hangovers and yeast but they
were not that they didn't plan they
played it some small role in this story
but I don't I mean I come to details
we have a squashing of a democratic
government by a dictatorship were very
one of the most brutal in totalitarian
of all dictatorships certainly and not
only did capitalism not prevent it but
as I see no evidence that capitals even
provided any kind of a defense I didn't
it's not even that they lost the war
somehow it was the capital is the fact
that was a capitalist country she'd to
play no role whatever in the
transformation the right take over so
it's it's so say IV the idea that
capitalism provides any kind of protect
and in principle it provides any kind of
protection then we can go the question
can capitalism be a threat to democracy
well certainly touched on that question
essentially the problem a beat of
democracy we're have political power
divorced from economic power this is
going back and the way to that quotation
from Marx that frezzer Cohn decided if
capitalism the you know the equality of
political powers the hands of a majority
and it may well be that it will take
steps which are anti-capitalist and when
it does those say against the owners of
capital against that those who are
profited by those are most profit of
most by the capitalist regime because as
bob says one thing we have in a
capitalist regime is very considerable
inequality I gotta say one thing I think
what happens in every regime is
considerable equality I'm not sure that
capitalism was any particularly
distinguished in this respect but the
socialist regimes have in fact a
suitable income inequality but whatever
it is you have but there is inequality
and very considerable inequality in the
capital and capital street shame and
then of course you have a divergence
between economic power economic power is
translated most political power the
united states were thinking of buying
the power but there are other ways like
buying a military power
instead of interference Democrats of
course we have in Chile 1973 we had it
in Spain in 1936 very much the same
story the left-wing government comes in
the Big South now wasn't that means
purely socialist as matter of fact but
as socialist and communist elements in
it immediately there's a
counter-revolution in this case it's
McCord in both of those cases because
the fact that there was a strong
military power why that's why the
military is kind of a third power and
that's why that's a separate power in
some countries and not in others is
something I don't is a fact but I don't
know why I don't have any explanations
for that so that's a case those are
cases at least in which and of course
Latin America will exemplify that over
and over again the the other cases in
which capital at which in fact a
capitalists interest or sometimes
sometimes even particular capitalist
interest rather than a general
capitalist interest can produce a
subversion of democracy of capitalism
may actually be a danger to democracy to
be fair about it I think that almost any
power structure in this say the civil
society the non government the non
political which differs strongly which
is powerful somehow and which differs
from the political majority I mean it's
kind of can leads a similar situation
some in the modern world probably ethnic
considerations have played some of the
same role that I'm ascribing here today
it's a capitalism but capitalism is one
of the dangers in this in this in
particular context now it's not very
clear as to why capitalism
is related to democracy in any
permissive way according to these
historical accounts and the other hand
it does seem to be an association it's
of course I our evidence is I should be
careful are evidence of substance is
dominated by one or perhaps two cases
maybe the Soviet Union in China Eastern
Europe I don't count was Eastern Europe
is to a very low mainly on the simply
that
Soviet tanks there's no great mystery as
to why East Germany in Poland and
Romania and so forth became communist
Yugoslavia is a bit of an exception that
way
it got their wit's own indigenous things
and there was this complicated story in
Czechoslovakia there was in fact a
strong in communist movement but not
true of any other countries a hungry
last free election gave a communist 10%
of the vote we could we on the whole and
even Czechoslovakia it's quite give the
Communists in Czechoslovakia we know
very well moved as those in Hungary to
for that matter
moved against even even a dissidents
within the Communist period could not
was not tolerated as we know in 1953 and
1960-1980 6 or 1968 or 1953 in Berlin as
a matter of fact the so I don't really
count those as examples of of capitalism
capitalism where's Martin sorry Julian
but by the course the interesting that
Soviet in China's since capitalism could
hardly have been said to be a well
developed phenomenon either of those
countries you know that was capitalist
elements all right but there was there
was a lot of non-capitalist element so
that that's why I said there's some
difficulty funny I mean capitalism I
think one would agree that pre-world War
one Russia was not a great example of a
well developed capitalist system there
were sectors of the country and it's
China even less so so that the take or
the communist takeover there are not
much evidence on the question of the
relationship so in a sense our
identification of socialism with
dictatorship in capitalism with
democracy in a way fails but there's not
many examples of the former and their
rather special then on the latter there
are a lot of courses I've said over novi
an authoritarian capitalist states
nobody denies that they're not even the
most blessed a fair economist Milton
Friedman says Greece that statement the
so another point of view which said for
whatever Association there is
that really there's a third variable
here economic growth summarizing a
lecture there's a a theory sometimes
called the Aristotle ellipse hypothesis
I think there's some quote lu aristotle
of course interpreting you know
aristotle on modern terms is always a a
at best the tricky business and
tendentious because the circumstances
was so different but there are some
ideas apparently our selling my Marty my
Sumer Martin Lipset put forth to some
view many years ago that and people
taking cross-sections and doing
statistical analyses claimed to find
this that essentially economic growth
leads to democracy and we have tended to
view that the economic growth is itself
stimuli or capitalism is itself so you
see a major enterprise in a development
of economic a major cause of economic
growth so this suggests that whatever
Association now by the way I mentioned
these as hypotheses that are advanced
and seriously studied the way they say
they're proved I think would be nonsense
and of course one thing is clear if you
fit statistically the variance around
the fitted lines is pretty there is very
very big for example there was one big
cross-section Allison signed dude Robert
barro and I where as you know I'm a
theorist and I look at the theory of the
model I looked at the reserve he
actually tabulated the residuals and
China was you know way off the economic
where the democracy in China was
registered a very low level well below
what would have Murr get predicted by
the economic growth of China so even if
there's some vague statistical
Association it's like a lot of these
other associations like like the alleged
relation for the intelligence and income
which is is there it's perfectly real
it's just not as big as nearly as big as
people think
and the evidence distich Elevens they're
unlike you know country comparing
countries is really dubious the case the
intelligence I think of we really we
have much better data and the evidence
is very striking them
now we're not likely to get so the
hypothesis we're discussing today in a
way it's not likely to get a test
because everybody says they're
capitalist today we got a clear mean you
can discuss as Baban not surprised those
who know us well let's be surprised by
political things are not very hardly
different from those of pop a lot of
statements together so I want to repeat
his points but of course I think it's
quite clear and I go at the from the
point of economic growth which is at
least helpful democracy I don't know
that we know any more than that is that
their capitalism itself doesn't work
very well when it's not well regulated
and not properly when there isn't the
checks and balances which can only
supplied by a democracy a democratic
powerful democratic states with and
access to free information by wall
citizens thank you
[Applause]
well our topic today is is capitalism
good for democracy but as a political
scientist I guess I think the great
surprise in human history is how good
democracy has been for capitalism and
the great surprise has been that even in
societies in which capitalism has
generated enormous inequalities of
property wealth wages and opportunities
the majority does not vote to confiscate
the riches of the super-rich the
majority does not vote to flatten income
inequalities through the tax system let
alone to overturn property rights or the
market economy and what I'd like to talk
about with you this afternoon is why
capitalism and democracy have been
compatible and whether this
compatibility can survive the
globalization of capitalism as we see
waves of cross-border flows of capital
goods and services transforming our
economies what's going to happen to the
fit between capitalism and democracy
over the past 200 years more and more
countries have come to have both liberal
democratic governments in which they
choose leaders in competitive elections
and at the same time free market
economies with private property rights
these two systems have coexisted with
remarkable stability despite the
inequalities that capitalism generates
no electorate anywhere that I know has
ever voted in free elections to overturn
capitalism there have been very strong
anti-capitalist political movements of
both left and right in Europe and in
Asia and in the United States indeed but
where political change has taken place
through free and democratic elections
anti capitalism has never won the day
now this result
democracy and capitalism can coexist was
not always taken for granted I don't
think you need to have been a Marxist or
Marx to have had a great doubt about the
potential compatibility of democracy and
capitalism in fact it was the great
anxiety of the founders of the American
Republic that democratic politics might
trample the rights of the propertied to
take the formulation of one of the
founding fathers James Madison he writes
in the Federalist Papers the great
danger in a democracy is that citizens
might organize they might mobilize they
might form a faction to push their
economic interests against property
holders and and here the I'm quoting
Madison now democracies have ever been
spectacles of turbulence and contention
they have ever been found incompatible
with personal security or the rights of
property in general democracies have
been as short in their lives as they
have been violent in their deaths so I
think the question we might start with
is why these dire predictions about
democratic government and an economic
system based on individual property
rights and on a free market economy have
proved wrong and I think they're
basically two reasons first the
constitutional engineering of Madison
and founders of other liberal democratic
societies did in fact work to protect
the rights of individuals and the
functioning of a market economy
institutions like the Bill of Rights the
Supreme Court federalism much else did
in fact build dikes that protect
property and protect markets against
Democratic majorities and secondly and
this is the point I want to focus on
this afternoon
democracy and capitalism have been
compatible all these years I think
because until recently capitalism had
been largely contained within national
boundaries government still stood on the
frontiers of their national economies
and they regulated the flow
of Labor capital goods and services
between their own societies and the
international economy within domestic
societies governments acted to cushion
the most disruptive features of
capitalism business cycles unemployment
inflation depression environmental
degradation now of course some liberal
democratic governments buffered and
regulated capitalism more than others
and in some times more than others but
what strikes me is that but in the
United States both Republicans and
Democrats like Social Democrats in
Scandinavia like the Tories in Britain
all acknowledge some measure of
government's responsibility and
government's capability for regulating
capitalism to mitigate its negative
effects to put it another way the
potential clash between democracy and
capitalism was averted by constitutions
that made our democracies something
other than pure democracies and by
politics that made our capitalism
something different than the textbook
models of capitalism not today I think
globalization threatens to undermine
this historic compromise and by
globalization I mean simply the
emergence of a single world market in a
single set of prices for goods services
capital and labour and of course there
are many changes that are driving this
forward new technologies the fall of the
Berlin Wall the worldwide liberalisation
of financial markets the rise of big new
consumer markets the rise of big new
producers outside the old developed
world globalization means that more of
the population everywhere becomes more
vulnerable to economic forces outside
their own country it means a widening of
the inequalities that we've already seen
grow in our own society and at the same
time globalization apparently reduces
government's capabilities
shielding citizens against markets in
fact far from shielding citizens against
the harshest blows of globalization
today government's credibility with
international investors seems to depend
on government's willingness to subject
citizens to the full force of market
pressures so for example in the Asian
financial crisis South Korea Thailand
Hong Kong they've virtually competed in
making commitments to impose the burdens
of adjustment on their own citizens
without regard to their relative ability
or their relative willingness to absorb
the pain now I think the result in our
own country and abroad has been the
growing fear of globalization the
protestors in Seattle and Prague may
look like marginal and violent
individuals but it's a fact that their
slogans make a lot of sense to many
ordinary mainstream citizens it's a
stunning fact to me that even after
years of economic growth and prosperity
in the United States that surveys find
that over 50% of people say that free
trade is bad for the United States
now what this reflects is undoubtedly
not economic sophistication but it is a
measure of the growing disease the the
sense of a loss of control over the
basic foundations of societal well-being
and I think many people fear that in
that there's no one who can be held
accountable for basic choices about
society's use of resources and society's
allocations of reward and risk when
citizens cease to believe that they
together with others can shape their own
future
then liberal democracies are in trouble
and I think that's the fundamental
challenge we face today it's not only an
issue of how to protect weak groups in
our society even though that is very
very important but I think the even more
difficult question in a world with an
international economy but no
international government is how to bring
globalization into the domain of human
choice and human decision how to bring
globalization into the domain of liberal
democratic process how can we make the
globalization how can we make capitalism
in a global economy compatible with
liberal democracy now I think one
solution to this dilemma could be to
provide individuals with resources that
would allow each person to protect
himself in the new economy and that way
we would reduce the burden of
expectations on what governments need to
do what kind of resources would we want
people to have well the kind of
education and training that would allow
a person to reinvent herself and her job
over the course of a lifetime we'd want
people to be able to diversify their
assets so as to spread family risks so
that for example an average family's
life savings and wealth would not be so
heavily concentrated in the ownership of
a house a home whose value depends on
many factors outside an individual or
the family's control and I think such
policies would be major gains in our
society and their policies on which most
of us can agree but even if we were to
imagine the best of education systems
even if we were to add a kind of minimum
safety net for those people who are not
intelligent enough or not agile enough
to take advantage of these opportunities
I think there still remains a big
question and the big question is are
citizens in a democracy willing to
accept that the basic social
distributions of risk resources and
uncertainties move so far beyond their
reach move so far beyond democratic
accountability and on this question
diagnosis and prescribe
Asians obviously diverge widely some
people think there's nothing that
government can do at the national or
international level to regulate
globalization Thomas Friedman who writes
on the op-ed page of the New York Times
put it in a very striking way he
describes a globalized economy as a race
of Formula one cars and he says if
you're worried about drivers smashing
into the walls what you can do is give
them better driving lessons and improve
the skills of the ambulance technicians
that clean up after the after the wrecks
but says Friedman you can't put bales of
straw all around the walls of the
racetrack to buffer the accidents or
else you're going to ruin the race if
you don't want to be a Formula One
driver then walk or bicycle but watch
out you're gonna be run over by a
Formula One driver now as a professor at
MIT for many years I've devoted all my
professional life to educating Formula
One drivers I know how much they
contribute to the giant leaps forward in
science technology and human
organization that are transforming human
well-being around the world and yet I
believe and I know from discussions with
my students that most of them believe
that we want to live in societies in
which the basic rules about the game the
basic rules about the race are decided
not just by and for the fastest drivers
but by all the people in our problem
like James Madison's is to find
institutions that will allow us to
reconcile democratic control and
capitalism the capitalism today is
global makes this the most difficult and
important of challenges MIT as I have
known it is a university driven by real
world problems
I think here we have one that deserves
our best thinking and imagination and
it's my hope for MIT and my hope for the
one to grow on for the school that we
can bring our Formula One faculty and
students together to respond to this
challenge
[Applause]
microphone coming here my comment is
directed primarily the professor arrow I
was listening
very interestingly and finding myself in
the funny position of agreeing with his
point of view while disagreeing
vehemently with one of the examples I
grew up in Italy in the 50s and 60s and
I can guarantee you that that
concentration of economic power was
indeed corrupting it we indeed generated
a lot of examples of everything from the
most base graft to the very program than
planned usage of millions of votes of
individuals who would benefit from that
system in order to support a political
system however you produce the to do
political arena no I'm thinking of the
area I'm thinking of at Mont Edison I'm
thinking of any and the various others
however it didn't work in the in the
direction of tyranny primarily because
as a population we tend to prefer to
discuss these things over a good meal
with a lot of wine and that tends to
calm the spirits and to focus on
important things in life but I do want
to say that over 15 years in this
country one of the items that I find
most interesting and I think the topic
of today's symposium is a symbol of it
is a peculiar obsession way
thinking that capitalism and democracy
are indeed connected and I'm wondering
if the question shouldn't be what else
besides the economic system be that
capitalism or socialism is indeed
conducive to the kind of remarkably open
society which I think this country is
one of the best examples in the world
there is of course an important point
which a little it's with one form but I
didn't go to detail which is when you
have an economy let's say capitalist
economy in conjunction with a political
system which has economic power state
ownership regulatory behavior you have
of course the question of translating a
power into the economic power translates
the political problem one form it takes
of course is straight corruption as yes
can be used by the government to try to
buy votes I think your points are
confused for personal gain if you get
privileges fundamental which is no way
for tea now one argument of course this
does lead to an argument or a very
minimal state which I think
unfortunately has other problems that
the inequality that arise in and even in
efficiencies that arise out of an
unregulated capitalism also involved
create create another set of problems
are different from the corruption
problems I think I think was Connors and
his direct remarks just at this there
always it's not a question of saying
that you will avoid problems it's a
question of saying we try to minimize
the tensions indeed one can argue that
if you have no problems you have no
progress either by the way so that the
tensions can be fruitful all I was
pointing out in it wasn't one thing it
was not used for and that was in there
was a that did it it affected the
democratic system
a perfected for performance the
democratic system I think was just
saying that it did not affect the
Democratic structure and this is of
course a problem can occur in
vote-buying
of all sorts you know one one typical
example yeah I say it's not it's not
anything threatening to democracy but
the complication is military
expenditures as local goods as providing
any income in local goods so most
extreme version is we have bases these
bases typically develop a relationship
to the local economy or thought off
probably not even correctly but they're
thought of as supporting the economy
anytime you try the Defense Department
is perfectly willing to have these bases
closed they have no interest in it many
of them it's not even it's not even a
question with military industrial
complex the military don't care in fact
they want they'd like the money but they
want it for other purposes and but then
you always have local Senators
Congressmen and so forth protecting
their interests so as soon as you have
that's example with there's some
economic power operating in some
locality and therefore generates local
things in the Texas oil millionaires and
the all of these the continuous buying
of special tax provisions which is
notorious all of these are examples when
as soon as the state has economic power
it's likely to lead to an attempt to buy
that power and you point out it's quite
correct that I'm sure that the Erie and
any involve themselves in I mean I don't
know the foul I'm taking works of the
facts but it's sir and logically I see
no argument against your position that
they once you have these powers that
you'll they will be used yes and the
only hope would be to create competition
other things which would make this
unsustainable
in the back
hi this is kind of for anybody on the
panel I've heard it said that it's a
good thing that the people who avail
themselves most of government services
are also the people who vote the least
and you see that to some extent evidence
by the 50% turnout that we see even in
presidential elections in this country
I'm wondering to what extent you think
that that economic power is able to buy
political power and discourage people
who might otherwise participate from not
into not participating how you think
that might be able to be reversed and
what you think might happen to America
if there was 90 percent turnout in terms
of political and economic distribution
well I'll leave that last part of the
question to Susanne already or anybody
else but I'm not sure that it's a very
good empirical that it's it's really
quite right to say that in the US for
instance those who use the government
the most vote the least I belong to one
class of people which directly
controverts that namely the old Kenneth
wants me to say retired that's that's an
organizational statement
I think that the I I'm not sure how good
that correlation would would be
middle-class people in the u.s. who are
generally the ones who vote get a lot of
benefits from government they they don't
much like paying the taxes that support
them but they don't mind the benefits
and they vote I think what governs
turnout in elections is much more
complicated than simply how much of my
annual budget is comes from the checks
signed by the Treasury there's an
enormous literature in political science
and on who votes and who does not but
what what I think is very striking is
how high the abstention rate is in the
United States compared to most other
advanced industrial countries and I
think there we have to go back to the
point that mr. Falcone made that there
are other factors that really determine
the quality of our democracy what is the
quality of the choices that people are
offered in the electoral system what are
the possibilities for participating in
various other in various levels of
government so I think that there's a lot
at stake here and there there is a
puzzle that's answered doesn't depend
uniquely on the economic system on the
empirics of this it is true that
lower-income citizens vote in smaller
rates than higher income citizens but
people who've actually looked at the
distribution of political opinion among
voters and non voters conclude that
there really isn't that large a
difference in the distribution of
political opinion so in order to think
that a large increase in turnout would
produce a substantial difference in
electoral outcomes what you'd have to do
is make a bet not that this is an unsafe
bet but it's the bet you'd have to make
you'd have to make a large bet that the
political opinions of non voters would
be shifted by the way they were
mobilized by people who got them to vote
but if you look static
at least so to speak the opinions of the
population as a whole look very much
like the opinions of the subset that
votes that's interesting because that is
an answer to the last part of the
question that's why I said my question
is for professor Berger you mentioned
that about when you were talking about
rules must be decided not by and for
Formula One drivers but by all people
what sort of institutions do you think
would be necessary for that to happen
for example Dani Rodrik at the Kennedy
School he advocates the conflict
management institutions when she
mentions democracy and social safety
nets etc education levels what in
European would be the critical
institutions necessary for full
participation and coverage as well I
wish I could give you an answer and I
think that the hardest part of the
answer is that the institution's we
would need would have to be more than
national institutions I mean the wide
said spread sense that the IMF the World
Bank are somehow determining the
fortunes of societies and yet citizens
have no way of affecting the decisions
of the WTO or the IMF of the World Bank
question is how do we sell how do we
provide some measure of accountability
of those institutions why is it that
that I mean we do have representatives
of our own national governments sitting
on those bodies and yet it seems to most
people to be a far too indirect linkage
to bodies it's that apparently are
making direct decisions about about our
social and economic welfare so the
problem that we have to solve here is
not simply how we change our own
national institutions but how we could
link how we could link national
governments to these international
bodies that's what I think is really the
the tough part here could I say
something yeah I have a question about
the about a part of Suzanne's argument
I'm not sure it's so clear that
globalization in the sense of a large
volume of international trade or even
perhaps although I'm a little more
doubtful about this a large volume of
international capital movements creates
such a drastic limitation on the ability
of national governments to regulate the
things that that really that really
matter I think the reason why in many
poor countries the national government
does not do the things that people like
us in this room would wish they would do
is not because they're in their
exporting and importing or even in large
part and even often not because they're
dependent on foreign capital it's
because they are either unwise or
corrupt or in any case unsatisfactory
governments on national grounds there is
an globalization has very little to do
with the tax system of even a fairly
small country which can do more or less
what it what it wants the trouble is
that they don't want to do I shouldn't
put it that way because it's not clear
whose volition is is involved here but I
don't think it's it's mainly
globalization globalization provides a
nice scapegoat for a government or party
or an institution that does not want to
do something that it might for one
reason or another does not want to do
and then back there yep go ahead
yes pursuing this question about
limitations like to ask and if you have
reactions to the Danish decision about
10 days ago not to join the euro area
because least according to the American
newspapers the reason was that they
feared that they would have to they
couldn't maintain their own safety net
and active government to deal with the
distribution of income and power that
you've been talking about now
Denmark is the classic small open
economy of economics has been involved
with an international trade very heavily
for the past century at least and here
they voted against joining a single
currency area and so I'm wondering
whether that's a critical limitation or
whether this is just the opportunity to
opt out of globalization or whether
something else entirely is going on in
the relationship between economic policy
and the ability of the government to
affect its own decisions professor peter
tevin whose question concerned Denmark
is the person from whom I've learned
most about the operation of the gold
standard and the way in which
government's credibility depended in the
19th century in parts of the 20th on
government's willingness to inflict the
burden of adjustment on its own
population and I think that that that's
really that in some respects that's the
political dilemma that we're looking at
again again today that that remaining in
an open market market which is in a
market which is open to capital flows
and short term capital flows as well as
as direct foreign direct investment well
puts governments in the position that
the Asian economies were in in nineteen
97 1998 a fearing that unless they in
fact imposed the full weight of the
adjustment on their own on their own
population as they would not receive
they would not be able to they would not
continue to receive capital from capital
from the outside world
I think I'm no expert on Danish politics
but it seems to be a judgement of the
Danes that they would be giving up some
valuable measure of political control
over the conditions of everyday life
Peter something is rotten in the state
of Denmark what what I don't know the
the argument that you described as
having been given doesn't make a lot of
sense the what the Danes voted against
was the European monetary union has has
little or nothing to do with their
ability to maintain their own social
safety net the the problem with with
social services and social assistance is
the European Union itself which proposes
eventually to have to harmonize as the
phrase goes social policy across the the
members I'm not I'm not I think what
myself the Danes were on about is that
they understand that the monetary union
is not an economic thing at all it's a
political gesture it's a it's a gesture
that amounts to some kind of semi
commitment commitment is much too strong
but as a step toward a political union
in in Europe and a small country living
on a little neck of land right near
Germany might not care much for a
political union in Europe and they I
think myself the vote against the EMU
was was a vote against that the it
certainly doesn't make sense to suppose
that it would really limit their
capacity
to maintain social policy this question
is addressed to Professor Berger the one
of the very strong point in your
presentation the argument was that the
national governments were doing
providing the institutional framework in
which people still within the capitalism
if there were certain disparities or
whatever but they felt that they had the
reach and they can make the basic
choices and the challenge is that that's
not happening now because of the
globalization and then you know there's
a connection in your argument saying
well this can be seen by the fact that
the people never voted against
capitalism never wanted to turn down the
property rights but you know if that's
the connection if I follow that
correctly then may I opposed to you of
course drawing from the experiences of
India that people are not voting against
government which are also allowing the
globalization to take place so if this
argument is that the people's you know
not voting against capitalist modes of
production capitalism and the connection
of democracy and goodness about it
within the nationalist boundary was
evident because of people not turning it
upside down people are not turning
upside down the globalization process
and their national governments elected
by people are taking decisions to move
into globalization's and integrate the
well so Hammond how do we see this -
which may appear I mean why would then
there will be a worry about this
people's helplessness about choices and
not being able to arrive in other worry
about being overrun by the Formula One
car where apparently by this logic they
are they're asking that governments to
do that and put them in that situation I
guess we have to ask whether people
actually believe that in voting for the
government's they've chosen in India or
wherever that they're actually voting
for globalization in fact parties
elections choices have been structured
around very different lines and what I
think is one of the most fascinating
changes of the
the last two or three years is the
globalization is emerging as an issue
which people see at stake in political
contests but it would be very difficult
for me to think that that the elect that
the rulers we chose or that Indians
chose in the 1980s in the 1990s that
people thought that by their choices
they were choosing the kind of
globalized world that we have we have
moved into elections weren't fought out
over those issues what people will think
once they think about politics in those
terms that that seems to me a different
point strikes me is interesting that the
that there are issues and I think
globalization is that what I've said in
the United States then that vote from
NAFTA or WTO that are where the elites
the political elite are different differ
from the country at all here we have two
presidential candidates firmly in favor
of globalization there's no there's no
way of voting for it in both cases we
know that significant members of that
party fact in the case the Democrats a
majority of the party has voted against
the proposals which are espoused by the
Vice President Gore and and certainly
within the Republican Party well it's
slightly different there there's a large
number who would probably follow Pat
Buchanan if they could otherwise stand
them on this issue and the same thing is
true I can discuss about capital
punishment to raise this very much the
same issues in Europe polls have
suggested the majority of people are in
favor of capital punishment and yet no
country in Europe has capital punishment
so there are situations in which the
political elite takes stands though
presumably if the people felt strongly
enough about it if that became the big
issue then you know that it would
overturn the other issues and people
would vote for it but when there there's
obviously a certain permissive attitude
on the part of the broad electorate and
I find this issue very interesting and
most of these cases to be perfectly
frank I think the elite is right and the
people are wrong
and my question then is the original
question of the relationship between
democracy and capitalism I here on one
part it's an historical accident because
it grew out of the same media and that
you would expect certain commonalities
of values and commonalities however the
way it evolves has to do with the way
people respond to things like the
application of brute force and the
application of ideas that spread across
boundaries and I think of this in terms
of Southeast Asia very often because the
Southeast Asian revolts and revolutions
if you go back to the Philippines the
Philippines became a model for the
Burmese revolt in 1988 which became a
model for the Chinese revolt in 1989
which was in a country that was a
curious mix of Chinese traditional
values and European ideas on politics
and I'm thinking that things tend to
spread and that the apparent correlation
that remains between capitalism and
democracy is a sort of convergence that
in fact what's happening is you're
getting a spread of ideas in their own
way and you're also getting people who
want to develop economically and there's
no real necessary correlation between
the two
thank you I wish a simple yes or no
would suffice there is of course the
diffusion of ideas is very old one of
the examples always liked is the
diffusion of foods from the new world
after its discovery think Italian
cuisine without tomatoes the or such one
take some really remote but
Chili Peppers these are all new world
products so they all spell these quote
great traditions are all very recent and
spread now however it's quite clearly
different places picked up different
parts of that say the student revolt of
the late 60s is another example
something gets spread very rapidly from
United States Europe imitation but it
takes different forms at at different
consequences because the cause of the
culture the needs of the particular
haven't played a big selective role and
the fact is that some of these things
fizzle out and do not bring permanent
some catch on and there is there is a
it's a little more complicated in saying
this is simply phantasm or imitation in
a crude sense there is got to be a
select it's like evolution I mean
there's a slight analogous to it's not
identical to if you know there's a
selection L there's a mutation own but
in this case an imitation element which
is we don't have an biology but it's
also a selection element and dyslexia
may be the more permanent and important
parts of the phenomena journalism may
depend on fads history may depend on
selection I've had the question that
Julian Wheatley has posed is really an
interesting one because I think we
really do have mental maps to link
together things that might might have no
necessary relation in necessary
mechanical relation and that a
particular kind of economic economic
system and a particular conceptions of
political freedom have become joined
together in people's understanding of
how the world works this is something
like what I guess Gramsci meant when he
talked about the hegemony of ideas
people's understanding that certain ways
of organizing society are necessary to a
good and decent and well-functioning
Society so I think that even if we could
demonstrate that there are no necessary
links between these economic features of
the economic system and particular
features of the political system that
you're absolutely right that these have
now become joined in a way where people
feel that they do in fact have to sign
on for the whole package that these are
not available that you can't sign
for one item on the list but it is that
they are in some way joins joined us
joined us as human possibility but then
it ought to be really very important to
piece out what is true and what is false
about the capacity to separate the parts
of the of the package salesmen of course
are always trying to sell you a whole
the whole package and and I suppose part
of the wisdom of shopping is to pick out
only the part that you want I think the
problem that that's being circled around
here is just that everything that
happened so to speak in the political
social economic realm is a mixture of
general principles and local
peculiarities the local peculiarity or
sometimes historical and sometimes arise
in some in some other way but the same
the same set of principles applied in a
place with one kind of institutions will
generate something a little different
from what we generate if the
institutions will otherwise I've got the
question for professor Berger it's
essentially no black an objection to its
argument that people don't vote against
capitalism and in my opinion what
happens that you can buy is the magic
coverage for instance the two major
party participated the beta another was
not represented there and what happened
you mas was that just two people with
liberalism ideas were facing each other
with somewhat the same global program so
I mean no socialist idea were discussed
there are no problems about union rights
worker rights stuff like that
same IP it's easy for capitalist to buy
concerns among people by agreement it's
easy to somewhat get agreement from
non-educated people and keep them
non-educators was in the feudalism and
it's somewhat the same now here in us
because good school are not easily
accessed
by poor people that can afford tuition
and stuff a that so my questions that
it's not just capitalist buying his own
agreement is own place in society and in
democracies well I mean I think that is
possible to buy something in politics
and I think everyone on the panel has
acknowledged how much in politics and
how much in electoral campaigns does
seem to depend on money but if you look
not at the United States with let's say
Europe you'll find large anti-capitalist
social movements large anti-capitalist
political parties communist parties
Catholic parties that were
anti-capitalist and that did receive
significant numbers of votes and
elections I didn't say that nobody voted
for anti-capitalist parties it's that a
majority of the electorate in none of
these societies has ever been able to
get itself together on an
anti-capitalist alternative and even in
societies in which there are strong
anti-capitalist alternatives the
majority of the electorate has not has
not has not made this choice
actually if I actually two years ago in
sorry a few years ago that's four years
ago in Italy the leftist wing go to the
power so it happened but I guess I would
say that's it's examples like this that
sort of wouldn't prove my point because
what had happened to the left before
they could win this election was the
left itself had been transformed we had
the the former communist Prime Minister
of Italy Massimo D'Alema
here at MIT explaining to us his
profound commitment to all of the
principles of market economy capitalism
nothing in what he said that in fact any
method virtually almost any Republican
might not have been able to you should
keep in mind that the United Kingdom
today is governed by what is nominally a
Socialist Party could you please comment
on the tensions between globalization
and individuality and self-sufficiency
certainly when it comes to individuality
if you mean individuality really in an
individual basis one could say that the
human beings are never more complete
than when they're in contact with other
human beings I does not think the having
a greater variety you grew up supposed
to a greater variety of ideas supposed
to a greater variety of choices of ways
of the examples of ways of life and as
well as economic you know what
alternative commodities is anything but
an increase in individuality now perhaps
you mean individual cultures this is
what people talk about you know there
was a French hero
I truly got three months in jail but
still these regard as a hero for burning
down a McNutt at mcdonnell's now it's
interesting who goes to McDonald's in
France it's not tourists
it's and now is this this could be could
be regarded is regarded course by some
people as something a deprivation of the
right of France to have its own cultural
thing so these these examples usually in
conflict turn out to be some kind of
local economic interests like protecting
farmers or something aircraft well
ask yourself sorry is about
self-sufficiency of course international
trade is bridge of self-sufficiency and
that we can go into the argument as to
what do you want self-sufficiency I
think I think it's a bad idea for every
point of view but that that is a
conceivable thing but a certainty the
the idea that most attachment to the
Japanese growing your own rice or
something like that that's not self
sufficient for the individual by the way
that self sufficient is Japan but it's
no way improving self-sufficiency of any
of any individual an urban Tokyo Tokyo
persons is what's the victim of the
Japanese farmers he would be of a tie or
American farmer well the exclusive is a
less extreme case because the Japanese
actually ordinarily exclude fine rice
completely and one of the fears
according to my Japanese friends they
will find that American rice is superior
and there's some evidence for that
a comment that Professor Berg can
respond to but I have a question for a
solo the comet is the race the race car
driver analogy to me fails because this
is the kind of race where and I don't
want two examples the drivers walk away
unscathed and all the spectators get
killed and pit crew gets killed next I
know a few drivers on beaches who are
unscathed so that's I don't think that
analogy works in globalization the
question are professor solo is of the
three remedies you mentioned and
everybody you've been talking about
buying of power you didn't discuss the
campaign finance reform issues that have
been so prominent whether I'm just
wondering whether that's because so
obvious or specific I'd like to ask
whether the extreme of making it a
publicly financed system would not be a
good solution or whether that's not
realistic to want that well you guessed
right I I did not I didn't mention
campaign finance reform because it seems
to me as I suppose it seems to everybody
in this room that that it's a
desperately needed thing and would be an
improvement for our political system so
I didn't think I needed to make a plea
for trying as best we can to diminish
probably never possible to exclude the
little role of big time money in in
politics I would think the are it's a
difficult legal problem I guess one way
and would be God knows would be better
for all of us especially students people
who have to read and work and things
like that is to shorten the damn
political campaign and and have less
time for the spending of money but it's
it's difficult to see how that can be
done without without violating
individual rights rights of free speech
and so on but I think that I don't want
to take too long about this
extremely important advantage that we
could create for ourselves is either to
go over to public financing of political
campaigns or to to do some quite drastic
limitation on what can be spent
my question is as everybody you all
agree that globalization is not just
walk into the microphone I said you all
agree that globalization is necessary
what I'm asking is that when America
wanted to industrialize most countries
that industrialized led after Britain
has to have to close their borders in
order to be able to grow the economy to
grow the new industries that will be
competitive in the market so what an
accent why shouldn't the developing
countries be allowed to do so because
globalization means opening the borders
and competition between young industries
and advanced industries so what I'm
actually in access its globalization not
a way of pushing all the polluting
industries to developing countries and
making benefit of it if not why can't we
allow globalization to permit movement
of level not only capital and and and
investment but movement of levels so
that it is globalization white whiteness
globalization against movement of level
if I understand your question correctly
and didn't you were saying if
globalization Chrissa free trade say
industries move from the United States
or other advanced countries into the
less advanced world and then you're
worried about the apparent you didn't
you don't regard that as a good I don't
know why I don't regard that was a good
solution by the way since enhance the
real wealth of the world you suggest
that instead of that you can have
migration of Labor
why is it that polluting industries
migrate to developing countries what is
happening is the rest of the bottom line
not even reached the bottom
industries that are highly polluting for
example recently America passed the
Africa route Opportunity Act and the
ethics more slowly
we're not understanding you he did not
understand me okay let me start afresh
why is it that when America wanted to
industrialize it had to close its
borders so that young industries could
grow and let it become effective to
compete with Britain as Japan said
France did and the unjam needed why is
it that in the period of developing
countries they would not be allowed to
do so and why is it that the developing
countries are not allowed to take the
responsibilities of polluting industries
because that's now the rest of the
bottom line not race to the bottom in
this case or the pollutant industrial
chemical industries design losses
ability to developing countries and it
is devastating the environment of this
in this areas and why can't we move Eric
lebas where to move around from
developed to development from developing
countries to developed country that's my
question you're really asking about two
things one what's the relationship
between globalization and the
possibilities for growth of today's
developing economies if societies like
South Korea Taiwan Hong Kong were able
to grow to some extent or Japan we're
able to grow in part they did do that
behind closed borders and one of the
possibilities if if we in fact impose
through WTO or impose through the IMF
and the World Bank o trade openness on
today's developing economies will we
will we hurt their growth and I leave
this question to my economist colleagues
here but I'd like to address the second
question that you asked and that is why
don't we allow free migration of people
across borders and in fact during the
first globalization the globalization
from the middle of the 19th century
until World War one there were far more
massive migration of workers across
national borders than anything we see
today and the result of that was that
that the price of the wages wages fell
in the societies into which the
immigrants moved
and wages rose in the societies from
which the laborers departed and I think
that there's a keen sense in in in in
today in our population that the massive
entry of new immigrants would be bad for
people's for the for the wages of the
existing population and so this is
politically and extremely unpopular it's
an extremely unpopular political move
that's why not that there's any justice
associated with it it's the luck of the
draw
which side of a border you happen to
live on let me just add one one more
point not to this particular issue but
to what I gather now you are asking
about if one of the characteristics or
one of the accompaniments of what's
called globalization is the free
movement of capital from rich countries
to poor countries then that is probably
the single most powerful force is
available for improving the standard of
living in poor countries the what
distinguishes poor countries from rich
countries generally is that poor
countries are labor rich and capital
poor and rich countries are capital rich
not always labor poor but but relatively
speaking highly capital intensive that
provides a natural advantage both for
capital seeking profit which is what it
tends to do and for poor countries that
find themselves without the capital
equipment that's the absolute and this
is absolutely necessary basis for rising
incomes per person for rising wages to
put it bluntly they should be welcoming
capital from abroad there is no reason
to allow foreign
corporations to dominate the politics to
dominate the culture to do any of those
bad things but the capital itself or to
be welcomed
yes this is directed to Professor Berger
pretty much we live in a ever
increasingly complicated feedback
network in the world
feedback networks are very well
understood particular here at MIT but
they're also prone to instability unless
they're designed very very carefully
could you comment on that in the context
of all of this could you say more I
think that it's a sort of poetry to say
that we live in a feedback network and
feedback networks are have the kinds of
characteristics that you mentioned
instabilities and whatnot unless they
are carefully designed but I called it
poetry because I think the direct
applicability of that sort of
formulation to the kinds of problems we
are discussing here is small very small
and the reason is that the elements of
the network you're talking about are
human beings corporations whole
societies government's legislators
terrorists god knows what and and we
know very little about the responses of
those elements to two simple shocks two
simple disturbances we don't know their
operating characteristics very well and
the the notion that you could you could
think of a whole society
the society we live in as a feedback
network we live in is perhaps a good
metaphor but I don't think at the moment
or for the next long period of time it's
going to be a metaphor that we can
translate into diagrams and equations
all right
I think Sweden has been mentioned a
couple of times here so I might have
just as well say something cuz I I come
from Sweden and I've been here for six
weeks and one thing that has strike
stroke strick know me as how how many
more choices Americans have to make
individual individual lists choices for
insurance and where to how to invest
your pensions and what telephone company
or whatever you you have to you want to
choose and this is something that your
rest
less regulated capitalism forces upon
you I guess if I would could put it in
half way and I wonder do you think that
this all these choices in the US are
they good for the democracy
do they make people feel more empowered
in order to participate in democratic
activities or equality things or is it
negative because it takes so much space
of the information flow you know
commercials and so or is it irrelevant
for democracy that's good well I think
it's probably accurate to say that the
availability of those choices is in the
American culture and at the American
level of income welcomed very few I have
occasionally tried the experiment of
walking into a drugstore and saying I'd
like some toothpaste and the salesperson
says what kind of toothpaste do you want
I said I don't care I just want some
toothpaste and you think that a good a
good drugstore proprietor would know
what brand of toothpaste is margin is
eight tenths of one percent bigger on
and would thrust a large tube of that
into my hand but no no I can't tell you
what toothpaste to have you have to say
what toothpaste even sometimes gone so
far say you know they're all alike and
no no but it's a funny experiment but
but the point the point is I think valid
this is this is a cultural cultural
economic thing but choice is generally
regarded favorably
now we all agree by the way the
political choice is a good thing one
could say yes but you don't have to you
don't have to choose your portfolio for
your pension fund and probably a lot of
people who do choose it would be better
off if somebody else chose it for them
but who they'd have to choose that
person in any case I don't know how
Swedes feel about restricted choice if
they are if they feel themselves as
being hemmed in and having choices made
for them that they would rather make for
themselves but on the whole it's it
sells in the u.s. to widen widen choices
that are available
well you're a multi-party system so
we're party when it comes to the booths
the polling booth
you obviously have more choice and this
doesn't seem to disconcert anybody in
sweden question and that is we've talked
to everything in the steady state and
the world population explosion is in
front of us and seems to me the biggest
thing is facing is you haven't mentioned
what effect that will have on capitalism
and democracy
well dr. Brannock is certainly right
that population growth is a very very
large phenomenon and and almost
certainly a problem for the world what
its effects on democracy will be a very
hard to to say as the world gets more
crowded there will be more pressure to
move across borders and this may have
influences on on the way we live our our
political lives if if increasing
population should in large parts of the
world not in all force down standards of
living that would certainly affect both
the way we organize our economies the
way we organize our but the we noticed
that the population growth is
concentrate in the countries where the
democracy is least well-established this
this I think is the thing or is the
average degree of democracy is going
down for statistical so to speak just
for pure counting basis back to the
countries of Western Europe are showing
remarkable and actually almost
incredible degrees of population decline
now of course one of the things in this
looks back to the links back to an
earlier observation is that you're
getting vacuums into which immigration
is induced to flow it's true that as
Professor Berger said the immigration
flows are not what they were around the
turn of the century the last century
hundred years ago but the but they are
there are large you know the kind of
Italy was a country of emigration that's
now a country of immigration and it
changes there are lots of problems in
assimilation connected with live
immigration which there are transitory
but as you as you as your question means
transition may be a long period and we
got to worry about what happens in the
transition but the real problems just
means the growth in countries with low
with relatively low Democratic
experience and this certainly if you
think of the idea which has been
suggested in questions about
international institutions and the idea
of responsibilities of international
institutions it seems to me this is a
good increasing bla a block to the
democratization of internet whatever it
is striking that institutions are what
some what anyone's called a responder
with the calibration ones called it a
responsible agencies they're not
literally a responsible but the links
are there they're autonomous and they're
the European Central Bank is incredible
there's no political counter here you
have a central bank running a money with
knowing no political counterpart and in
the short run they're perfectly good
reasons why that happens and I'm sure it
will run very well for a while or you
worry about the long run of was what the
long run is and and I think the attempt
to the idea of discharging you know
increasing the role of international
institutions which which there are
obviously a lot of pluses is gonna be
held back by the demographic imbalance I
can be prepared to give up their
sovereignty to such organizations it's
an instance of our that when you make an
agreement with speakers you give that
there's a kind of contract you enter and
get a certain privilege which is the
privilege that you end at the time you
promise them to end that even when most
of the people in the room who have their
hands up would like to keep going so I'd
like to thank the speakers for a
wonderful session
thank all of you it's time to end these
two days that I thought were spectacular
thank you very much
[Applause]